[Musica]
[Applauso]
lo sapevo è stata
però
la ricetta di fiamma pensavo fosse una
ricetta di un dolce di un gelato di un
frullato Ma che cosa ti sta
succedendo Penso che qualcosa non ha
funzionato correttamente mi sto per
trasformare il lupo mannaro no dove c'è
un lupo mannaro
non posso io il lupo mannaro Quindi
ancora peggio no Fammi vedere questa
ricetta
la ricetta
dell'ululato
[Musica]
Ma tu appena hai letto questa ricetta
dell'ululato Senti è venuta
in mente
fermarti il lupo mannaro che credevo
fosse una ricetta
esotica ho letto io no non ululato
ululato mi sono sbagliato lo so fa pure
rima Aspetta un momento stamattina tu mi
hai dato un frullato non era lo stesso
che hai preparato vero oh non era lo
stesso era diverso dagli ingredienti
diversi
allora nel mio nel mio ho messo i peli
di Merlino è un
canidetta richiedeva capito Cioè la
ricetta richiede i due peli di cane
quindi ti sei bevuto
[Applauso]
Aspetta eh Tu invece hai bevuto quelli
di Circe perché vedi C'è la variante coi
piedi di gatto
cioè
[Musica]
se non ha funzionato su di te guarda la
parte positiva è vero Io non ho niente
di diverso non ho neanche una cosa
quindi per fortuna su di me non ha
funzionato ma ora dobbiamo subito
trovare un antidoto per te prima che
informazioni sui completi era quello che
stavo cercando di fare qui con il libro
di fiamma ma il quaderno di fiamma Ma
noi non ho trovato niente cerchiamo
qualcosa che cosa sono questi ad esempio
e Quelle sono cose strane di Fiaba c'è
anche una cosa galleggiante qui è un po'
bruttina allora
Ma che cosa stai dicendo mica bevo
questa schifezza così ti sei bevuta e
periti Merlino
Ma questa puzza Beh i feriti Merlino Non
puzzavano un pochettino Sì ma vabbè
Merlino
Beh
ha funzionato No non credo che abbia
funzionato ci sono ancora tutti i peli
Oh no come
facciamo allora da quello che mi ricordo
tutte le altre volte che abbiamo
affrontato i lupi mannari abbiamo
utilizzato l'argento vi ricordate c'è
scritto anche nel mio libro A proposito
Voi ce l'avete storie paurose e ora o
addosso una collana d'argento quindi
possiamo fare qualcosa con l'argento
proviamo dai
Poi se poi mi fai del male ma che sto
cercando di di trasformarti Dai tocca
questa collana
non sta succedendo niente
sta trasformato ci sono più peli se vi
viene voglia di
questo specchio è un po' Strano magari
possiamo provare a specchiarti e magari
provi a dire una formula allo specchio e
può funzionare Magari provo io a dire
una formula allo specchio l'ho visto in
qualche film in dei film funzionava
allora che quello può essere la formula
Quale può essere fammi pensare
qualcosa a che fare con l'uva mannaro
sicuramente aspetta prima Guardate allo
specchio Okay
il lupo mannaro mi invento una rima
Torna come prima
[Musica]
Vitale
mi sa che non ha funzionato per niente
[Musica]
per fortuna sono riuscita a nascondermi
bene il lupo mannaro Vitale non mi ha
trovato ma ora cosa faccio Devo riuscire
a scappare dentro casa senza farmi
vedere la porta per fortuna è rimasta
aperta proviamo ad entrare
andiamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
devo assolutamente trovare una soluzione
il prima possibile
Ho avuto un'idea
C'è solo un modo adesso per uscire da
questa situazione devo chiedere aiuto al
nostro amico il lupo Next Ve lo
ricordate se non sapete di cosa sto
parlando vi lascio la casellina alla
fine di questo video così vedrete tutta
la storia in cui abbiamo conosciuto il
lupo ex dal mio libro storie paurose
scuola di misteri voi ce l'avete ma ora
non ci resta che chiamarlo come si
faceva
bussare tre volte e girare due volte non
me lo ricordo ma l'ex aiuta abbiamo
bisogno di te
come faccio
Chi mi ha chiamato
ah ah come stai No come stai Anzi dove
sei finito Dove hai finito
il mio cocktail e della spiaggia in una
spiaggia che cosa ci faccio qui dov'è il
mio costume Dov'è il mio costume
cioè vedi in costume da bagno Sì in
spiaggia stavo per entrare in acqua per
il mio bagnetto
pensa ma che io mi fanno il bagnetto Io
non sono un lupo sono un lupo un po'
umano ok Vabbè comunque ti ho chiamato
per una questione molto urgente è molto
importante che cosa è successo Perché mi
hai chiamato quale l'urgenza
praticamente Vitale ha provato una
pozione da un libro di un Alchimista
fiamma tu ancora non l'hai conosciuta ma
forse la conoscerai e da questa funzione
lui si sta trasformando si stava per
trasformare il
[Musica]
E certo che glielo hanno dato in cambio
di un filtro d'amore sapete che c'è una
bella cagnolina Ma questa è un altro
discorso che adesso non è non è non è
affare vostra non è importante quindi
che cosa possiamo fare come siamo messi
Qual è il piano hai un piano vero
[Musica]
vero
tu sei un lupo anche se sei un mezzo
lupo mezzo lupo mezzo male comunque tu
conosci i lupi meglio di tutti sei
l'esperto mostrolo no E quindi Devi
aiutarci devi farmi capire come posso
fermare questa trasformazione ti serve
vedere la Formula magari qualcuno Vitale
[Musica]
Ah eccolo però questo la ricetta
la ricetta
dell'ululato no Ma come dell'ululato Ma
No Questa ricetta è stata Bandita tanti
secoli fa come Bandita Ma sì è una
ricetta proibita non dovrebbe essere qui
da questa parte del mondo
quindi siamo a usare i sette proibite lo
sapevo che nascondeva qualcosa ma ma
quindi che
Cosa vuoi Allora se io qua vicino
Ah damostrologo forse potrei fare
qualcosa in più ma sai son rimasti
dall'altra parte del mondo nel mondo
delle Creature l'altra parte del mondo
In che senso Cioè c'è un altro c'è
un'altra c'è un altro mondo sì non ti
avevo mai parlato pensavo di essere
arrivati a questo punto molto molto più
avanti ma visto dove siamo ho visto
questa situazione Sì il mondo è diviso a
metà da una parte c'è quello degli umani
dall'altro c'è quello delle Creature Beh
io posso andare in tutte e due i mondi
perché sei mezzo umano è mezzo lupo
Brava esattamente Ma magari un giorno
riuscirò a trovare un modo per
prenderlo per voi Beh No in realtà c'è
un problema perché le creature noi le
Stiamo affrontando qua quindi deve
esserci stato qualche problema tra il
mondo delle creature e il nostro mondo
reale perché ogni tanto compaiono le
crea anche qua Adesso capisco cosa erano
qui con i terremoti sulla spiaggia Deve
essere veramente successo qualcosa o
qualcosa che
ancora Chissà magari un giorno
arriveremo a capo di questo problema Sì
infatti questo è un altro mistero che
dovremo risolvere ma Adesso pensiamo a
salvare Vitale Come facciamo a farlo
tornare normale allora da quello che
posso leggere qua ci sono un po' di
ingredienti Sì un po' strani un po'
particolari come per esempio i peli di
carne cosa avete fatto a prendere i peli
di cane Come avrà fatto Vitale ha preso
i peli di Merlino Merlino il mio grande
amico Merlino Quindi da quello che posso
leggere qui a parte la banana ti
immagino che sia stata questa a fargli
venire voglia di proseguire e fare
questa ricetta Sì io vedo che qua ci
vuole Sì a parte il polline sotto la
luna piena va bene ma i due peli di cane
quelli non sarà semplice annullarli
perché vedi questi ingredienti insieme
generano una fortissima combinazione
alchemica e non sarà semplice annullarli
Oh no ma ci deve essere una soluzione un
antidoto qualche altro ingrediente che
può funzionare per far tornare lievitare
normale prezzo però prima
che tu sicuro sicuro
Sì sì va bene posso correre questo
rischio ci facciamo quattro risate
perché sai qual è l'ingrediente quale il
peperoncino il peperoncino
normale uno che raggiunge i 2 milioni In
una scala Scoville quindi è fuoco puro
Ah semplicemente il peperoncino a farlo
tornare normale non capisco qual è il
collegamento Alchemico
in realtà non lo so neanch'io
esattamente qual è il processo Alchemico
quello Bisognerebbe chiedere la fiamma
Beh chiaro è normale no ma io credo che
sia un qualcosa del tipo particella di
lupo mannaro
un qualcosa così
Ok l'importante è che tu sei sicuro di
quello che stiamo facendo quindi mi
basta prendere un peperoncino e
darglielo da mangiare no sì ci vuole un
peperoncino potentissimo Eh ce l'abbiamo
[Musica]
Io adoro il piccante io non la sopporto
perché poi vedi anche io sono un po' una
creatura farebbe malissimo anche a me
Beh è vero Se anche tu sei il lupo è
meglio se ci stai proprio lontano allora
facciamo così io faccio un esca per
Vitale e poi c'è un peperoncino là fuori
sul tavolino noi ci nascondiamo qua così
osserviamo eh aspettiamo che Vitale
caschi nella trappola e vediamo se
funzionerà ok Questo sì che è uno Ottimo
piano andiamo facciamole
ok
[Musica]
Va bene vado a prendere il peperoncino e
torno subito
Io ti aspetto qui Ok guarda che quello
arrivo e vai di me mi fa fette Eh sì io
e veloce Subito Vai veloce corri
Ma è quello
No
quello è una farfalla
ho trovato un peperoncino con un
altissimo livello di Scoville
praticamente si assaggi solo un pezzetto
di questo peperoncino
e fuoco puro è piccantissimo Ma io
dovrebbe i peperoncini per quello che ce
l'ho perché mi piace piccante Lo so è un
po' strano però non lo so Mi piace un
sacco Ma vabbè comunque dobbiamo mettere
questa trappola Vitale non vedo l'ora di
vedere la sua reazione quando assaggerò
questo peperoncino super piccantissimo
Andiamo adesso ho lasciato l'ex da solo
e non vorrei che sia combinando qualcosa
quel fifone andiamo
ho trovato un peperoncino con un livello
di Scoville Altissimo sei sicura fammi
vedere
[Musica]
e poi Speriamo che Vitale sia attratto
dal profumo del cibo e arrivi subito Ok
tu fai la guardia e controlla che che
non arrivi prima prima che io sia
tornata dentro la camera Ok ma nel caso
in cui stia tornando che che possono
fare che gesto ti posso fare che cosa
faccio faccio un fischio faccio una
scoreggia Uh uh uh uh che faccio
Aiutami Non lo so esci fuori e aiuta mia
a sconfiggerlo in quel caso no no no no
no no no così no no non mi piace che me
ne torno in spiaggia io ma come si può
aiutarci
mamma Alex Sei il solito fifone Non ti
preoccupare non arriverà adesso Vitale
vado a Piazza Va bene io ti aspetto qui
con Merlino ok
[Musica]
Ok Alex ho piazzato letto Speriamo che
Vitale rubama non arrivi subito
che cosa facciamo oggi nascondiamo e
aspettiamo giusto Sì io ho trovato già
il mio nascondiglio ed è dietro al
divano Tu dove ti nascondi ehm
non credo che mi veda qua vero Ehi
Merlino Oh partita lì
Eccolo è arrivato
stanno usando
dai mangiano mangialo non sembra molto
interessato no se n'è andato Non l'ha
mangiato
non ha funzionato
no l'ex il tuo piano non ha funzionato
Vitale hanno usato il peperoncino deve
aver capito che era piccantissimo e non
ha mangiato Cosa facciamo adesso
dobbiamo fare in modo che
quell'esca sia più appetitosa ok Come
come non lo so Me lo devi dire tu che
cos'è che gli piace a Vitale
in realtà mangia tutto è un grandissimo
mangione Ma soprattutto è golosissimo
gli piacciono tantissimo i dolci I dolci
Perfetto allora Ma i dolci di che tipo
Tipo
una torta i dolcetti che cosa gli piace
Beh gli piacciono tutti i dolci però non
saprei dove nascondere il peperoncino
forse
è serio montata per nasconderlo la panna
montata quindi piatto di panna montata
Montagnetta di panna e un'idea lo
sbricioliamo dentro
sorgerà che se il peperoncino dentro
andrà a mangiare la panna lo mangerà e
tornerà normale Spero che funzioni
funzionerà vero funzionerà ma non sarà
un bello spettacolo sarà molto doloroso
Ripeto per lui E vabbè Mi dispiace ma è
l'unica soluzione almeno tornerà normale
non sarà più un pericolo Ok vado a
prendere la panna vado subito a
posizionare la panna tu fai una guardia
Ok se arriva qualcuno avvisami
come glielo metti la mamma Ah è vero
tieni questa
adesso Tieni Anita non c'è io tu prendi
uno spuntino me lo faccio anche perché
non ho mangiato niente in spiaggia
Allora vediamo non riesco cioè troppo
grosse vediamo
[Musica]
eh eh
Questa è la panna che dobbiamo usare No
scusa scusa stavo solo vedendo se
funziona Ecco tieni tieni
mi ricordi tanto Vitale
Io sì mi manca
Vitale
Hahaha Sicuramente sei più peloso Vabbè
vado a prendere il peperoncino ok Ho
ripreso che il peperoncino piccantissimo
adesso adesso allora prima mettiamo la
panna Uhm
mettiamo un bel po' giusto Ok
mettiamone tanto il mio mondo
una montagna Io sono la montagna Fai
così in montagna Wow
Mi sembra perfetto perfetto Ok E adesso
risaliamo il peperoncino
[Musica]
perfetto E ora aggiungiamo ancora un po'
di panna e vado subito a mettere la
trappola ok Questo sì che è un
capolavoro e tu adesso cosa dici questa
ma non mangiarla potrebbe servirci
ancora Ok molto
Speriamo che funzioni questa
e ora aspettiamo
No no no
ma l'ho lasciata lì non c'è cascato
deve aver sentito l'odore del
peperoncino
cosa facciamo Non lo so Aspetta ho
un'idea è un po' drastica e un po'
pericolosa anche Ma è l'unica soluzione
per salvare Vitale salvare anche noi
non seguiva in silenzio Ok spero
Vitale
Oh Oh Oh che schifo
il peperoncino sembra che si sia
trasformato in uno Yeti adesso sembra
L'uomo delle nevi
l'ho visto uno ed è proprio così
sta arrabbiando
[Musica]
deve aver sentito il piccante adesso
Poverino lo andiamo a vedere se sta bene
Vitale Vitale Come stai
bene e tu come stai
presto
torniamo ok
ciao ciao ciao
sei resa conto di quello che è successo
no sono soltanto che c'è un buonissimo
sapore di panna no
[Musica]
Chissà se c'è qualche altra ricetta
segreta proibita qua nel diario di
fiamma
lex ha detto che fiamma ha usato una
ricetta proibita Chissà che cos'altro
nasconde Vabbè l'importante è che su di
me non abbia avuto effetto quella
pozione
[Musica]